if you are stuck in a nine to six
or even a nine to nine because you have
two jobs in your situation such a
challenge because you're feeding four
people in your home as a single parent
and you've got two jobs you're nine to
nine the question is can one of those
because one of them's just extra cash
instead of having a five to nine where
you're actively doing something can you
get a five to nine for the same fifteen
dollars an hour at a store or be a
receptionist or a night guard where you
can work on your phone while you
actually do your job you know this
concept of people saying well i'm stuck
it's true because you think you're stuck
the actual
world doesn't think you're stuck you
just haven't figured out the move you
have to make to unstick you and that's
exactly what i just said in that little
scenario right now if you are
pessimistic and you say you're stuck
then it's over
if you've decided it's over there ain't
no [ __ ] video i can make to make you
on over